hi I'm Erik Bosse and Game of Thrones
season has officially arrived with the
trailer set in the crypts of Winterfell
that is filled with symbolism and hidden
meaning and hey it's longer than a few
seconds like last two promos word am i
gonna do with all this time whole 90
seconds times 24 frames for a second
that's like 40 million still images not
really a numbers guy let's break down
this cryptic trailer for all the details
that you might have missed it's more
than warning the case setting my
predictions in the beam right and
they've ruined your life let's get
started
[Music]
okay so this promo appears to be shot
purely for marketing purposes like I
kind of doubt this footage will appear
exactly as is in any of the episodes in
season 8 past few seasons have actually
built up hype in a similar way with
creepy symbolic promos with the actors
this crypts of Winterfell promo echoes
both the long walk promo for season 7
and the Hall of faces promo for season 6
the heroes walking their destined paths
but the destination being death all men
must die even if it will necessarily be
these exact characters in this season
the only real confirmed footage that
we've seen so far are the brief clips of
John Sansa and Daenerys and the others
greeting each other at Winterfell
which will take place in the season 8
premiere that episode will reportedly be
filled with callbacks to the Game of
Thrones pilot episode and already we're
seeing one major callback here be grave
of Leon a stark and the feather in the
hand of the statue that feather was
placed there by King Robert Baratheon in
the very first episode when he visited
Leon his grave in the crypts and growled
about his lingering rage toward the
Targaryen Spore
as he and we all believed the Crown
Prince Rhaegar Targaryen kidnapping and
raping and killing Leon it Robert told
Ned Stark that when he and Liana were
betrothed he would bring her exotic
tropical birds because they were her
favorite and this feather was meant as a
token of those memories later in season
5 Sansa would find this feather on the
floor and place it back in the statues
hand repeating this myth about her
aunt's date how many tens of thousands
had to die because Rhaegar chose your
aunt yes he chose her and then he
kidnapped her and raped her but if
you're thinking about this really the
more appropriate token to leave only on
the storks tomb would be a blue winter
rose the flowers that Rhaegar gave Leon
at the tourney of Harrenhal
because in reality their love was true
in consensual Robert's feather was
likely a gift she wouldn't really be all
that interested in John's passing by
like my mum didn't want you a fever and
it's John passes a statue we hear her
dying wish to her brother from the Tower
of joy flashback in season 6
and notice how John turns I said they
heard this whisper from his mother the
Block in here is almost exactly the same
move Ned Stark made in that Tower of joy
seen the moment bran called out to him
and young Ned almost seemed to hear him
I'll get more into this possible
connection between John and Ned later
but for now let's move on okay in this
section in Sansa Stark walks past a
statue of her mother Catelyn Stark we
hear Kaitlyn's voice from an episode in
season 3 when she confessed to to Lysa
that she actually prayed for Jon Snow to
die she talks about how when baby John
came down with the pox Catelyn felt
horrible for wishing him dead so she
prayed again to the gods this time to
spare the boy promising to treat him
like a son and demand med give the
bastard the stark family name but even
when the boy was spared she never kept
her promise and she fears that all the
tragedies that have befallen the stark
family started with the curse that she
brought upon them but while the gods may
have played a role in the Starks
destinies it may not be the curse that
Catelyn feared like really these sad
events needed to happen for Jon to
ascend to his current position king of
the north partner to Daenerys also while
we're looking at that moment I think
it's worth pointing up the exact words
Catelyn used to describe baby John's
close call with death
they still do insane if he made it
through the night you do but it would be
a very long night ah the long night is
the name given to the last severe winter
in Westeros that lasted an entire
generation this is 8,000 years before
the present day it was the first time
the White Walkers descended upon
Westeros and it looks as though we're in
store for a second long night in this
final season which we can assume will
lead to another close call with death
for John perhaps the events of season 8
could spend an entire generation as well
like we could see a time jump to an
anchor John in older versions of the
rest of the surviving characters after a
lifetime of resisting against the White
Walkers
we'll see another possible clue pointing
to this later on so let's move on to the
next clip
you are a stock you might not have my
name PR my plot
okay one more past quote here this one
from Eddard Stark taken from his final
moment with Jon Snow in season one you
are a stone you might not have my name
behind my blood the next time we see
each other we've talked about you mother
so yeah all of these past quotes are
about Jon the key elements of his life
his birth when Ned Stark lied about his
lineage to protect him but also dooming
him to the position of a bastard and as
many close calls with death we're
reminded how as a baby that God spared
him as they will do in Kenan again
throughout his life and of course the
secret of his royal lineage clearly
Jon's whole life journey will be very
important to this final season and it
looks like it could cause some tension
between him and Sansa Arya
the man who is once their half-brother
will now be revealed as a cousin in a
Targaryen and an auntie in rewatching
these past clips I'm getting a little
nervous that that conflict between these
characters could have actually been
foreshadowed Jon left you in charge he
did I hope he comes back soon I remember
how happy he was to see me when he sees
you his heart will probably stop maybe
she's thinking on some level that she
might end up stopping that heart by
sticking them with the pointy end huh
next clip
okay so here we see the three starts
destination their own grace
Aria sees her own tomb statue Sansa her
own and John is look apparently it was
done by the same sculptor who did that
Lucille Ball statute sure this statue
doesn't make John look a lot older than
he currently is compared to Sanson Aria
statues which pretty closely reflect
their current appearances this could be
because statues of stark men tend to
make them look older wiser more kingly
whereas statues of stark women that
we've seen tend to look younger or
fairer so coming in to tragically
premature deaths like whit Liana
also it's just not easy to sculpt facial
hair it always looks like they're
wearing fake beards or you know those
knit caps that go over your face
but if this is depicting an older John
that could be more evidence of that time
jump Theory like maybe John will die in
season eight but as an old man after a
long life of battling white walkers in
the second long night but really we
should remember as far as this promo
goes I think this is all meant to just
be chilling imagery hinting at the end
of all these characters narratives and
their perennial proximity to death the
way that the Hall of faces promo did but
let's move on to this final clip
okay the three Starks face an oncoming
freeze from the White Walkers John
unsheath small claw the Valyrian steel
sword given to him by Jorah Mormont Arya
pulls out needle the sword given her by
John and seized one now that story
probably wouldn't be very useful against
the White Walkers
but notice how you can also make out the
dagger hanging from areas other side
this is a Valyrian steel dagger that
belonged to Littlefinger it was used to
attempt to murder bran by the cut throat
and Arya ended up using it to execute
Littlefinger this weapon will probably
end up saving all his life the image of
Roberts feathered Ileana freezing over
isn't just powerful to show the
impending danger facing Winterfell after
breaking through the wall the night king
and the white walker army really just
have last hearth and then Winterfell is
next on their death march this image
here suggests the myth that inspired
Robert's rebellion and the Wars of the
past are really being shattered by a new
more important truth also the image of
this lone feather being taken over by
Frost reminds me a lot of that earlier
teaser promo for season 8 with the board
map of Dragonstone a similar iciness
spread across that table with the stark
wolf freezing over just like the feather
does it's a visual depiction of the word
Sansa quoted from her father
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
on the shirt here the three Starks
unified as a pack are able to barely
thinned off the looming cold but this
leaves us with a big question because
not all the Starks are prison here
why doesn't brand join them well for one
brand doesn't really identify as a stark
anymore since becoming the three-eyed
raven his perspective has really shifted
above the politics of Westeros to a more
existential plane I can never be motive
Winterfell I can never be Lord of
anything in the three-eyed raven but
also bran might not be entirely absent
from the scene remember there was a
moment with John at his mother's grave
the turn just like Ned turned at brands
voice there were these important
memories related to John's life from
Catelyn and Eddard I think bran is
present here speaking to John through
the voices of his parents both his
biological mother and his foster parents
Ned and Catelyn using them to help John
discover who he really is and of course
I guess we can never really rule out the
possibility that bran has worked into
the past and become the night king you
know that old crazy theory that we've
talked about before
and maybe the night king is two mouths
like adult brand thousands of years old
and this icy mist means night King brand
is actually here and the Starks are all
present but yeah I'm not gonna put all
my chips on that theory this trailer
ends with the reveal of the season 8
premiere date April 14 and the marketing
slogan for the throne and that brings me
to my question for you guys what do you
think for the throne really means is it
simply a battle between warring factions
for control of the Iron Throne Lannister
versus Targaryen versus night king or
could it be a rallying cry to unite
realms of men against this supernatural
evil the throne being the one symbol of
the Targaryen conquest and the unity of
Westeros and another question do you
think it's possible that we could see
this footage as part of the season
common down below with your thoughts and
follow new rock starts on Twitter at new
rock stars and you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at be a boss and
subscribe to new rock stars for a game
of thrones updates and breakdowns and
some fairly far-fetched but still fun
theories like how judging from this
promo Game of Thrones final season could
be half forrest gump and half day after
tomorrow
ha confirm